yes dear friends
I think
each of us has so his 1.
male highlights
be it now perhaps the first kiss
or even the first job
I like to tell about a special 1st time
and exactly from this moment
where we stood opposite each other
tingle in the belly
looked us in the eyes and then it happens
there i have my brand new german passport
of the border policemen presented
and this wait
this wait in this eu snake
the first time as eu citizen
is a very special moment for me and
that's why this is also a highlight for me
now i have the attention
so i am there college then
I am 31 originally come from montenegro and
yes live here in germany since october 2013
here in beautiful bavaria and
the reason why i moved here or
the motivation was
a measure in international relations
in which installed at the Catholic University
ingolstadt to make
motivated by
that i was born at a time
where my country yted
where many armed conflicts in the balkan region
have taken place
I was four years
than the
when the srebre anissa massacre took place
eight when the kosovo war changed
and 14
when my country montenegro became independent from serbia
and these events have my family
the company
where I grew up
and me personally very shaped
and it was a transition phase
where one or one could be relied upon
and nothing at all
the political crisis was
too big and the hostile one
the hostility between the peoples in the country
even much bigger
than most balkan countries in 2009
have joined the official application for eu
started a new euphoria
hope that we will find ourselves in a united europe
and in this hope euphoria
I have also decided
just after my engagement in albania
studied international relationship here
to study because i wanted to study in the u
i wanted to live in the eu
i wanted to meet this society
and then later also
accompany this further process of these countries also
i have been here for nine years now and this
this stay has enriched me
but even if nine years have passed
I am every time
when i pass a eu border from germany
still without passport control
with so much freedom to cross the boundaries
and I know that is not a matter of course
but for me something very big
but this freedom is not a matter of course
people die at the eu border
millions of people are excluded from this and
i would like to advocate for this with me jp
that we,
as green
we as european green
for a stronger solidarity and a europe
To be used with full cohesion
thank you very much